explain this but he has some of that
this is odd of all the questions we had
the one that came up most often was us
benedict to say the word penguin what is
this about well I probably I got it
wrong repeatedly in the documentary it
wasn't a documentary about said animal
there's a documentary about I think
about the South Pacific in general and
now I'm completely terrified of the
words I don't go near because I know
here's the thing I thought oh they're
making it up but we actually look
documentaries are both strange Islands
the first one you sort of get away with
and then after that you lose all sense
listen carefully and the last thing you
might expect to see here
his penguins these are Fiordland crested
penguins named after this corner of
South New Zealand so why are these
Woodlands so attractive to pangalanes a
freshwater stream through the forest
makes a handy highway for a parent
penguin heading home from a fishing trip
comes great phantom and a long great
phantom come weirdos we discussed this
on the show before I don't know do you
aware of this Johnny Depp that when
Benedict became famous one of the first
things that happened was his fact this
is so random that his fans decided that
he looked very like an otter are you
aware of this we shown these were these
are these are these are classic other
auto auto you know a creature him and
yeah yeah you don't think about so
here's a classroom what mine would be
here's a classic officer
is more expressive water and see an X re
you would think no how can you look like
this and here you go
the Harry is good you're just matching
some pictures of Austria yeah favor
there's a really viral and that'll be
great people like the Farah pictures of
me in an otter would go and see a film
about it thank you won't be splashy this
first officer this first heart I'm
afraid does it fire it's the dark side
of the officer Kingdom this is angry ah
sir
[Applause]
[Applause]
but yeah don't we I mean no it's either
music or it's or it's it's bits voices
or tongues of voices I mean you know ice
and muck around with dictaphones at
school for ages and just you know do
interpretations impersonations of people
and great characters and it's just sort
of having an ear it's part of what we do
I guess I mean even if it's not a real
person just to imitate or have empathy
with a state or a human being of any
general you were doing - back at during
the clip what I'm with the two back of
being just natural watcher that's one of
my favorites you back a moment is just
that
[Music]
stating the obvious but Benedict is
pretty good at acting I know
laughing you did me and you were very
good you did my laugh very well the
dragon is back he is a crystal finished
business a voice that there isn't I mean
obviously it's put through treatments
and things but actually yes it sounds
very like what you did no God
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
is time for benedict cumberbatch to meet
Benedict Cumberbatch this is Madame
Tussauds what are they called a wax
figure they're not wax work the wax
figures all right yeah gland you haven't
met it yet no right so come with me come
on come over here all right everyone
come over have a look have a look have a
look so this is gonna be spooky so come
down here come down here okay
you all set yeah okay oh yeah here is
better to come back feast your eyes on
you
[Applause]
[Music]
you know it looks so like you that's
spooky the back of the head never saw
these tired even looks as tired as I
feel okay do it do it do it yeah yeah
nice nice
we all come in have a picture taken with
this mm-hmm you must be hot take a
run-up ready okay camera over there
somewhere
ready okay one two three
[Applause]
look at this okay look at this now we
needed the face of it you've never seen
a happier creature on planet Earth
look how happy this holler is with his
new teddy bear depressed I've been given
to a mammal I said that the command I
talked to my phone I went will need a
big teddy bear
now however the big the word big is
quite relative yeah they've gone with a
really enormous teddy bear
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's it's just there's something I don't
know there's something about it that
makes me want to kind of do
[Applause]
keep it there think of the Kyoto
I mean what does he want cuz you were
like a nerds wet dream
Sherlock Star Trek and now Marvel thank
I know that's that's your pension right
there you can just actually just go and
sign pictures of box there's a there was
a shot that I think you were on location
in New York so this is this is without
the special effect
Doctor Strange is that the what do you
call energy rubber bands take off will
you take yeah that's me about to fly
okay anyway for some reason the way
these things do that image just captured
people's imaginations they've taken so
straight you put it in different places
so here's Benedict and as it's choir
it's also very sporty very cultured
music is his life
I'm very good at the ice-skating ladies
and gentlemen Donald Trump move
what I've had a word with Disney I just
I need to check that I have said it
correctly
[Applause]
[Music]